großbritannien und der iran
beschlagnahmen öltanker in der straße
von hormus spitzt sich die lage zu und
der bau der erdgaspipeline nord stream 2
ist äußerst umstritten werden
öllieferungen aus dem iran strengen
sanktionen unterliegen heute in vechta
kompakt europas kritische energiezufuhr
[Musik]
eine gesicherte energieversorgung gilt
als wesentliche voraussetzung für die
wirtschaft sie hat außerdem eine
sicherheitspolitische komponente den
energielieferungen gelten auch als
strategische waffe
sie können als druckmittel oder als
belohnung eingesetzt werden einseitige
abhängigkeiten das hinterland gefährlich
weil sie die handlungsmöglichkeiten
eines staates stark einschränken
russland hat diese waffe seit der
auflösung der sowjetunion bereits
mehrfach eingesetzt
das haben vor allem die baltischen
staaten und die ukraine aber auch
moldawien und weißrussland zu spüren
bekommen
durch überraschende exorbitanten
preissteigerungen oder
lieferunterbrechungen wurden sie
mehrfach und der erheblichen
wirtschaftlichen und politischen druck
gesetzt
die eu-staaten sind in hohem maße auf
importe angewiesen 87 prozent des rohöls
werden eingeführt bei gas sind es 70
prozent
dabei sind zwei aspekte von bedeutung
das ist einerseits die liefersicherheit
durch den führerstaat und andererseits
der ungestörte transport über gewässer
oder der transit vom herkunft zum
verbraucher landen deshalb wird eine
verteilung auf mehrere lieferanten
angestrebt um ausfälle möglichst rasch
ausgleichen zu können
in der regel besteht eine gegenseitige
abhängigkeit weil die förderer auf die
einnahmen und investitionen der kf
angewiesen sind und diese das öl und gas
dringend benötigen beide seiten
überlegen sich daher gut
ob oder wie weit sie dieses geschäft
gefährden und für politische zwecke
einsetzen wollen
das gilt auch für transitländer die
meistens gut daran verdienen
der öl und gas begünstigt kaufen woher
beziehen die eu staaten nun öl und gas
der größte öllieferant war 2018 russland
mit 27,3 prozent dahinter nur wegen mit
11,2 prozent ziemlich gleichauf lagen
die guerrilla mit 8,1 kasan mit 7,8 die
irak mit 6,9 und saudi arabien mit knapp
6,6 prozent ähnlich im gasbereich hier
nehmen russland mit über 40 prozent und
norwegen mit 35 prozent eine
herausragende position ein
algerien liefert mit 11,3 prozent schon
deutlich weniger gefolgt von katar mit
58 der gesamte gasverbrauch betrug 2018
etwa 480 milliarden kubikmeter davon 55
milliarden kubikmeter in flüssiger form
dem sogenannten elend die lieferungen
aus den usa steigen zwar sprunghaft
anliegen mit geschätzten 20 milliarden
kubikmetern aber bei nur drei prozent
89 prozent des import gases fließen
durch pipelines die drei
leistungsfähigsten kommen aus russland
nord stream die ja mal europa und die
sogenannte bruderschaft diese befördert
auch gas aus zentralasien nord stream 2
soll die lieferungen durch die ukraine
ersetzen ingesamt strategischer nachteil
für kiew ähnlich verlaufen die
ölpipelines die bedeutendste heißt
freundschaft greenstream befördert gas
von libyen aus sizilien algerien
exportiert sein gas durch die mitgas
nach spanien und europa zu
liefersicherheit in einigen
förderländern kommt es immer wieder zu
terroranschlägen oder bewaffneten
konflikten siehe irak libyen oder
nigeria
auch manche transitachsen gelten als
gefährdet zum beispiel über den
südkaukasus oder die osttürkei die
spannungen zwischen moskau und der eu
könnten ebenfalls zu problemen führen
der bau von nord stream 2 wird von
einigen eu mitgliedern heftig kritisiert
eine blockade der straße von hormus
durch die etwa 20 prozent des jährlichen
ölbedarfs transportiert werden hätte
natürlich ebenso auswirkungen auf die
versorgungssicherheit vor allem aber auf
den öl
im großen und ganzen laufen aber derzeit
die lieferungen in den eu-raum
störungsfrei sieht man von förder
schwankungen in libyen einmal ab die
krise um die creme hat 2014 viele in
europa wachgerüttelt von der eu wurde
eine energie union ins leben gerufen die
fünf dimensionen umfasst die
energieeffizienz einen integrierten
energiemarkt forschung und innovation
die dekarbonisierung der wirtschaft und
die versorgungssicherheit
dadurch sollen der kohle öl und gas
verbrauch gesenkt die isolation einzelne
mitglieder beseitigt und die
abhängigkeiten reduziert werden
da betrachtet sie die importe auf
möglichst viele anbieter zu verteilen
moskau möchte aber die abhängigkeit
europas erhalten sowie kontrolle über
andere lieferanten erlangen
dafür investiert das massiv meist über
den staatlichen energiekonzern gazprom
die pipeline netze oder förderanlagen
zum beispiel in südosteuropa aber auch
in afrika
washington hält den iran vom
europäischen markt fairen und wirft der
eu die erhebliche abhängigkeit von
russischem öl und gas vor
als alternative biete präsident
amerikanisches flüssiggas an
ein ausblick es gibt zwar keine hinweise
auf eine akute gefährdung der
energieversorgung
aufgrund der zunehmenden geopolitischen
spannungen ist aber nicht auszuschließen
dass energielieferungen ausfallen oder
als strategische waffe eingesetzt werden
könnten
die eu sollte daher als öl und gas
käufer geschlossen auftreten ihren
bedarf an fossilen rohstoffen deutlich
reduzieren und durch möglichst viele
anbieter abdecken
dabei ist es wichtig sich von keiner
seite unter druck setzen zu lassen und
eine europäische energiepolitik zu
verfolgen